people think I max is just about a
bigger screen size while we do have the
biggest floor-to-ceiling wall-to-wall
curved screens IMAX is so much more it's
digital and film cameras with the
largest resolution format out there
producing stunning large screen images
like no other and IMAX digital cameras
that are able to best optimize clarity
and detail for our screens its DMR a
proprietary image enhancement process
that goes through every frame so you can
watch the movie with the clearest
sharpest images just as the director
intended it's a specialized custom
theater environment designed to open
your field of view to an average of 70
degrees allowing you to fully immerse
yourself in the film it's projectors
with brighter colors and patented custom
design sound systems that can reach an
entire octave lower than traditional
speakers so you'll feel like you're part
of the action
every scene the theater specially
positioned for optimal fuel for over 50
years
IMAX has been bringing all these
elements together to deliver the most
immersive movie going experience in the
world of IMAX films to the fullest
you